nearly a half million students in
Oklahoma could miss school today because
or Monday rather because of a threatened
teacher strike teachers are asking for a
ten thousand dollar raise over three
years Oklahoma ranks 49th among states
and the District of Columbia for teacher
pay Omar Villafranca is at the State
Capitol in Oklahoma City where lawmakers
passed a measure yesterday that raises
taxes and teacher pay Omar good morning
good morning the starting pay for a
teacher in Oklahoma is just over
30-thousand dollars and they haven't
received a pay raise in more than a
decade state lawmakers passed a 450
million dollar tax hike which is
expected to put about 15% more into
teacher paychecks but educators say it's
still not enough we achieved something
that we all thought might be impossible
after months of growing calls from
Oklahoma teachers for better wages state
lawmakers passed what's described as the
largest teacher pay raise in the history
of the state Oklahoma's Republican
governor mary Fallon signed the bill
into law on Thursday took many different
tries putting packages together in many
different ways to help us have
sufficient revenue that raise would
increase teacher pay by an average of
about six thousand one hundred dollars
Alicia priest is the president of
Oklahoma's largest teachers union
educators wanted a ten thousand dollar
pay raise but since lawmakers fell short
of that amount she's urging teachers to
walk out of class next week we must
ensure that every student in Oklahoma
has the resources and opportunities they
need to succeed and that's why we'll be
at the Capitol on April 2nd
the potential strike in Oklahoma follows
teacher walkouts this month in West
Virginia and Arizona we're going to
demand that all teachers in Arizona are
given a 20% teachers they're saved a 20%
raise would keep educators from moving
to other states that offer better pay I
feel like I should be making a livable
wage I have a college degree and 17
years of teaching experience and two
kids who count on me Oklahoma City and
Tulsa Public Schools were two the two
largest districts in the state plan to
close their classes on Monday because
teachers still plan to walk out buses
though here in Oklahoma City for their
schools they will still run but only to
deliver meals to students who depend on
them
Gayle all right Omar got it thank you